no es esta bolsa de malla la que se cree
que mató a daniel brühl como se ven en
las imágenes de la cámara de policía los
oficiales colocaron la llamada capucha
anti escupitajo mientras tenía una
crisis psicológica y de drogas inducida
que oficiaría a pro dos minutos más
tarde para el sindicato de policía de
rochester nueva york
los oficiales no hicieron nada malo esa
noche del 23 de marzo y tenían que hacer
exactamente lo que hicieron
tenían deben entender las frustraciones
de nuestra parte también cuando tenemos
que hacer los procedimientos y
protocolos que tenemos no hay opción de
cambiarlos en absoluto amnistía
internacional ha condenado el uso de
capuchas anti escupitajo por parte de la
policía diciendo que las bolsas pueden
ser peligrosas cuando se usan en
personas en peligro para los
manifestantes de rochester la muerte de
plutón en primer plano la cuestión de
cómo la policía se enfrenta y trata las
emergencias de salud mental y de drogas
los manifestantes dicen que los
trabajadores de la salud y no los
oficiales armados son necesarios en
tales casos y que brut es otro ejemplo
desgarrador de la brutalidad policial
que debe
[Música]
en este punto se siente como si no
estuvieran escuchando porque sigue
sucediendo una y otra vez así que espero
que con estas protestas cuanto más
fuerte nos pongamos a alguien más nos
escuchará y con suerte se producirá un
cambio los manifestantes continúan
coreando sus nombres vidas de
afroamericanos a cortadas a manos de
oficiales de la policía ya se abrieron a
taylor que fue asesinada en su casa
george's floyd cuyos últimos momentos en
un estrangulamiento policial provocaron
masivas manifestaciones raciales en eeuu
y en todo el mundo hoy echo play
gravemente herido tras recibir un
disparo en la espalda un espectáculo de
violencia policial que ha sumergido a
muchos estadounidenses en una discusión
sobre la demanda de cambios en el
tratamiento policial hacia los
afroamericanos en eeuu